well done Joe got the chopper
it's place for congratulations
hippies are it happened in the last drop
I draw we need an assistant funny thing
is I've been a janitor I'm more at home
in that role than is the director only
Artie here seems to see that yeah hi
Artie look we need to get the lockdown
lifted otherwise I can't get to the
other sectors can you help me get to the
override yes yes easy be easy it's just
around the corner but first we need to
get you working very small couple of
hours chop something tells me it's gonna
be more than that you would think there
is a dog buried in this I can tell you
are not yesterday's grouses son that's
why you make a great assistant very well
I'll hit the facts on the table
miraculous were that his house has a
vermin problem a bad one they've already
messed up the cooling pumps at the power
generators of a power plant politically
and the pensioner inside he started to
fill top and around his head tighten the
situation needs to be fixed before the
plant blows up and we all disappear like
a fart in Sahara
trying my best to keep up with this fix
the coolant pumps and the power
generators otherwise the power plant
will blow but don't you worry I've left
you clear instructions your constant of
the threat before I go to my vacation
the words or the desk port here you can
do later when you have done vacation
right yes
always gotta cancel my holiday or seeds
burn a rattle but don't worry at all
you'll take care of it and soon this
crisis cannot be last with there is no
you better go now
so you don't have to run with your head
as your third leg the door in the back
leads to the plant the door in the back
that's great thank you ah tea
what's down that way whoa oh this place
makes me nauseous
object of power how do you think it got
down here
a carousel horse why is kid stuff always
a creepy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man hey chief of rish FBC security
shouldn't you be in a safe room they all
love HRAs we're on the same side my name
is Jesse Faden I'm here to perform the
directorial override to get the lockdown
lifted yeah yeah chief of reshef PC
security I'm just oh hang on you're the
new director it's a pleasure
ma'am let's skip the formalities please
right
Faden ma'am look as you can probably
tell it's a bit of a [ __ ] show down here
we've been holding our ground but
whatever's gotten into our buddies
hasn't reckoned the coolant pumps and
the power converters the NSC keeps
overheating and my crews keep getting
shot before they have a chance to make
any repairs NSC sorry bureau jargon it's
what we call the power plant no the big
rumbling metal thing Salvador had a
security ask me to protect it in case of
an attack see what's inside is dangerous
the dr. darling seemed to know it would
be a target darling he's here no he came
down a few days ago before everything
went to hell he was out of it it smelled
like a bar mat he was ranting about
vulnerabilities and how he only had one
large-scale hrá but that he needed it
somewhere else still at least he gave us
these personal hrs before he left
hey did I mention that he was tearing
his clothes off crazy dude Darlene knew
the hiss was coming listen I love
playing 20 questions as much as the next
guy but we have got to get the water and
electrical systems repaired before this
baby blows I'll have my guys unlock the
doors out of here for you I'll take care
of it you stay and keep the hiss away
from the plant if you can this that's
what we're calling him that's catchy
listen the radio is not working so if
you find my boss salvadore out there
could you please ask him what the plan
is I'm sure he will have one by now I'll
keep an eye out for him he sure has a
lot of faith in his boss
try to stay alive
[Music]
[Music]
my work blaze departs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell is that
[Music]
we need to hurry stereotypes
now let's take care of
[Music]
you